i want to make a quick correction or
clarification to the last video that you
may or may not have find compound
confusing you may not have noticed it
but when i did the general case for
multiplying a row by a scalar i had this
situation where i had the matrix a and i
defined it as it was an n by n matrix so
it was a 1 1
a 1 2 all the way to a 1 n then we don't
went down this way and then we picked a
particular row i so we call that a
i 1 a i 2 all the way to a i n and then
we keep going down assuming that this is
the last row so a and 1 all the way to a
and n and when i wanted to find the
determinant of a this is where i made a
i would call it a notational error
when i wanted to find the determinant
the determinant of a
i wrote that it was equal to it was
equal to
well we could go down in that video i
went down this row that's why i kind of
highlighted to begin with and i wrote it
down so it's equal to to do the
checkerboard pattern i said negative 1
to the i plus j well let's do the first
term i plus 1
times a i
a i
1 times its sub matrix
that's what i wrote in the last so if
you have if you have a y 1 you get rid
of that row that column you have the sub
matrix right there a i 1. that's what i
wrote in the last video but that was
incorrect and i think you know when i
did the 2 by 2 case in the 3x3 case
that's pretty clear it's not times the
matrix it's times the determinant of the
sub matrix so this right here is
incorrect and of course you keep adding
that too and i wrote a i
a i2 times its sub matrix like that a i2
all the way to
a i n times its sub matrix that's what i
did in the video that's incorrect let me
do the incorrect in a in a different
color to show that this is all one thing
i should have said the determinant of
each of the determinant of this guy is
equal to
the determinant of a is equal to minus 1
to the i plus 1 times a i 1 times the
determinant
the determinant of a i 1
plus
a i 2 times the determinant
of a i2 the determinant of the sub
matrix all the way to
a i n times the determinant
of the sub matrix a i n
it doesn't change the logic of the proof
much but i just want to be very careful
that we're not multiplying the sub
matrices because that becomes a fairly
complicated operation well it's not that
bad it's a scalar but
we're what we find the determinant we're
multiplying times the determinant of the
sub matrix we saw that when we first
defined it using the recursive
definition for the n by n determinant
but i just wanted to make that very
clear